about John Chapter 2 what about it go
ahead course you can ask me so what
about
it um I Heard the you discussing the
wedding in in Cano galile right and it's
very deep because it shows the
intercession of the Blessed Mother it
shows the it resonates with Genesis
however I get lost a little bit on the
discussion about the wine because
obviously what is the one point to in
the
gospels the cup that uh Bally the blood
of Christ right right and what do the
six jars though but before you go on I
want to see if you got what does the six
jars
represent the six jars the six jars yeah
that's kind of what I want to get to
like what what does it say what were the
six jars it's there in the text yeah
what are they nearby six of ceremonial
cleansing of the Jews they would fill
the water to use to perform their ritual
cleansing
okay you see it there yes okay what day
is the banquet taking on the wedding
it's the seventh day it's the third day
but if you count from John one this why
if you followed the order if you count
John 1 19 you're G to count this is the
seventh day which is the third day
because when John is speaking in John 1
19 to 28 and then it says the next day
he saw Jesus that's day two right right
John 135 the next day that's day three
right
right and later on it says the next day
the fourth day right and now this is the
third day so four and three is
what four and three is what yeah he's
seven yeah so he's uh so six days of
working but the seven day is the day of
rest right yes so the seventh day is
when the buing bank is taking place but
it's also the third day because on the
third day and the third day points to
Jesus's resurrection because it's his
resurrection that ushers in every
lasting rest got it so how do you enter
your rest not through the Jewish system
of ceremonial cleansing that's six days
but you enter the seventh day of rest
through faith in Christ who through his
resurrection brings in Everlasting rest
wow okay did you not catch it six jars
that's six days of working Jewish
cleansing so the Jewish way will never
bring you into the seventh day God's
rest
only Christ can and he did it by his
resurrection from the dead where he
ushered in
Everlasting rest for those who would
trust in him so that's why it's on the
third day and it's the seventh day so I
enter God's Rest by faith in Christ who
through his resurrection from dead on
the third day ushered in Everlasting
rest salvation and the wine is the blood
of the Lamb that cleanses me of my
sin awesome so in this case is it like
the Blessed Mother saying to Jesus it's
time to bring them rest well in the
context she represents Eve the woman
right woman but what it's showing you is
that unlike the first Adam who sinned
when he obeyed the voice of the
woman this woman when the son yeah you
got it right yes yes because what did go
God say in Genesis 3:17 because you obey
the voice of your wife and did what I
told you not to do curs it is the ground
because of you and what does the ground
produce well it produces you know
thistles you know Thorns but it also
produces
Vines right and what is wine made on out
of the fruit of the
vine
right okay so the first woman right the
first man when she obey when he obeyed
her this woman was not a curse but
actually turned out to be a blessing
because she hastened the hour in which
Christ would begin his work of bringing
Everlasting
rest wow it BL my mind same because I
also remember when you mentioned before
that Noah when he drinks the wine
actually he gets drunk and you can read
it in a way that he didn't know that he
would get drunk so he
was he would know that because this is
something new right a new experience for
him right yeah exactly so two connects
right because this new wine is the true
wine it doesn't make you dry but gives
you life like it cleanses you because
the purification rights of Judaism
cannot cleanse you it's only the blood
of the Lamb that cleanses you that's why
it's not going in six jars and what did
he say was used for the water in the
jars were used for ritual Jewish
purification right yes so Judaism cannot
purify you only the wine can purify you
which is the blood of the Lamb
wow fantastic wow what a passage so
that's how deep the passage
is Mary is a new Eve and a better Eve
because what she told him to do the Lord
honored her and had the son do it
hastening the beginning of his ministry
in ushering in Everlasting
salvation and then when the master of
the banket says um he talks about
basically everyone serves the best wine
first and then the cheaper wine because
the old test wasn't God's ideal it's the
New
Testament wow without sinking in
wow the Old Testament the old Covenant
is not God's ideal God saved the best
for last it's the New Covenant in his
blood wow blows my mind so
deep I'm glad to ask you the question so
that now making sense yes yes and you
see that Mary is important in that
because it was her request that ushered
in sped up the hour of Christ beginning
his work of bringing in Everlasting
salvation and
rest point this the first woman brought
death and caused the man to sin against
God that's why God said because you
heard her voice this woman the father
himself honored and had the son go ahead
and because of her request hasten
meaning sped up the hour of his ministry
yeah how do I know the father proof
because Jesus says he only does what he
sees the father doing John
5:19 right so if he went and did the
miracle who was doing the miracle with
him the father and his Spirit and the
spirit that means the entire trium God
honored her by doing what she asked wow
so what do you say to a Protestant when
he just thinks that Mary's just ordinary
when the Trinity honored her and sped up
the hour of Jesus's Ministry due to her
request to show her the honor and love
that they have for
her now it's crazy and I I read
sometimes they don't even know why she's
called woman there right they get
confused no we know because it's
connecting it with the last Adam the
last Eve who ushers
in a new Heaven new Earth and restores
the garden that's why in Revelation the
last chapter you have the Tree of Life
Genesis Tree of Life lost revelation 22
Tree of Life regained CU you see in
revelation 22 right verses 1 and 3 says
on on other on either side of the river
of the Water of Life was the Tree of
Life which was given the leaves were
given for the healing of the Nations